to present the award for outstanding
achievement in art direction here are
two of the durable glories of Hollywood
fresh from their brought in sugar babies
the man who won an Oscar 41 years ago
and is nominated for another tonight
Mickey Rooney and a lady whose taps have
punctuated the greatest American musical
films and Miller
ladies and gentlemen the nominees for
outstanding achievement in art direction
are Damien art direction by Michael
Seymour less Tilly and Roger Christian
set directions by Ian Whitaker all that
jazz art direction by Philip Rosenberg
and Tony Walton set direction by Edward
Stuart and Gary brink Apocalypse Now art
direction by ding Taveras and Angelo
brand set declaration by George ara
Nelson
the China Syndrome art direction by
George Jenkins set direction by Arthur
Jeff Parker art direction by Harold
Michelson Joseph R Jennings Leon Harris
and John's alone set decoration by Linda
de spinner and B envelope here a winner
let her go yes all right let's get it
out the winners are Philip Rosenberg and
Tony
we're very grateful to Bob Fosse for the
visual concepts that he gave us to work
with and to pepino row to know for
photographing them so magnificently and
we'd also like to thank our executive
producer Dan Melnick and our associate
producers kenneth 't and wolfgang
glottis for their encouragement
throughout the picture thank you thank
you to the Academy and thank you to the
whole gang that Phil mentioned and I
thank special thank you to Robert Alan
Arthur who sadly wasn't able to see the
completed film but was enormous ly
responsible in the starting of it and a
special thank you for Bob Fosse and
Peppino to know for making us all look
good I would just like like to thank a
crew in New York City who is second to
none without them I wouldn't be here and
also my lovely wife of 40 years who took
a lot of nonsense me and all that time
and thank you all just like to offer a
special thanks to George the Tita
Richard a D and Bob Platt who helped put
this movie together for us